[Music]
welcome back to cvs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with an unlikely
discovery off the coast of england
that's where an avid snorkeler stumbled
onto a forgotten piece of the region's
nautical history thankfully had the
skills and the gear to bring his fine to
the rest of the world mts tayab has the
story
it's world famous for its miles of sandy
beaches historic fishing villages and
now the picturesque norfolk coast on
england's eastern shore is attracting
global attention following the discovery
of a century-old shipwreck
three weeks ago the remains of this
vessel which last sailed in 1896 was
spotted near the town of sheringham by
local snorkeler and filmmaker chris
taylor you were snorkeling you weren't
deep-sea diving
is it normal to discover a wreck just by
snorkeling i don't think so i think i
just got lucky it was uh just a lot of
uh you know the weather the the
clearness of the water the sand not
being there and me just happening to
swim sure at the right place it was just
all uh all came at once i should have
bought a lottery ticket on a rainy
november night 125 years ago the ss
commodore was carrying coal to london
from newcastle when the ship ran aground
all 14 sailors made it safely ashore but
the commodore sank into the seabed
considered a hazard it was intentionally
blown up six years later leaving these
remains now so clearly visible from
above from the drone taylor uses in his
filmmaking he sent images to a local
museum to confirm his find
looked at the shots and said yeah that's
that's the ss commodore and they were
they were really quite excited because
it hasn't like i say it hasn't been seen
this clearly for a long long time since
taylor's discovery residents of
sheringham have flocked to see this
remnant of the past visible now
but maybe not for long
for cbs saturday morning in this tayyip
london
pretty cool never know what you find
when you go out for a little snorkel
yeah